Louis-Philippe Ouimet a passé
5 minutes en sa compagnie.
♪ ♪ ♪
(cliquetis de  m machine)
Patrick Senécal, le Salon du
livre, ça va être l'occasion
idéale pour vous de faire
des séances de dédicaces, mais
en tanquque roi du roman noir
au Québec, quel est le moment
le plus étrange que vous avez
vécu dans un salon du livre?
PATRICK SÉNÉCAL, auteur
- Ah, mon Dieu! J'en ai eu
quelques-uns, parce que, avec
le genre de roman que j'écris,
c'est sûr que... il y a
des lecteurs et des lectrices
qui viennent me voir avec des...
des fois, des requêtes un peu
étranges. Il y a une femme
à un moment donné qui estenenu
me voir, qui m'a dit qu'elle
avait vécu, elle avait été
possédée 43 fois. Elle venait
de lire "Sur le seuil",
puis elle avait écrit un livre
elle-même là-dessus, puis
elle me l'a donné en disant :
"Vous lirez ça, c'est ce qui
m'est arrivéanans la vie, puis
je pense que ça ferait un bon
film." Ça, c'est toujours un peu
malaisant quand  r rencontres
des gens comme ça.
Je me suis fait inviter aussi
dans une soirée échangiste
dont leur thème était "Aliss",
mon roman "Aliss", la soir
du Palais. Puis ils ont dit
qu'ils s'étaient inspirés de...
Ha! Ha! De mon roman
pour la soirée échangiste.
C'est quand même sympathique
comme invitation, mais j'ai
décliné.
(musique sinistre)
- Votre premier roman à succès,
"5150, rue des Ormes",
a été blblié en 94.
Aujourd'hui, ça semble évident :
Patrick Sénécal, célèbre,
il vend beaucoup de livres.
Mais, au début, là, est-ce que
ça a démarré lentement ou
rapidement?
- Non, non, ça... Moi, j'ai...
Non, non, j'ai pas été la saveur
du mois en partant, là. Moi,
ma carrière, elle a fait
ça comme ça, là. Ça a vraiment
été... "5150", je pense
qu'on en a vendu, je sais pas,
là, la première année, on a
peut-être vendu 1000, 1500.
- Il était là àhahaque fois...
- C'est sûr que le film
"Sur le seuil", quand le film
est sorti en 2002, il s'est
passé quelque chose. Ça, c'est
clair, ça m'a fait beaucoup de
publicité. Il y a plein de gens
qui ont voulu lire ce que
je faisais. Puis, l'autre
gros coup de ma carrière, celui
qui a fait que j'ai pu arrêter
d'd'enseigner et de devenir
un auteur à temps plein, c'est
mon roman "Le Vide" en 2007.
Ça, ça a été un autre... Puis,
pourquoi? Je sais pas, mais
c'est le roman que je memettais
le plus en question pendant
l'écriture. Trois, quatre fois
j'ai failli l'abandonné
en disant : Ça marche pas,
c'est... Le monde y croira pas,
c'est trop ambitieux comme
roman, c'est trop compliqué,
tarabiscoté, tout ça. Puis
finalement, bien, c'est le roman
qui a fait de moi l'auteur
que  s suis aujourd'hui,
jusqu'à un certain point, là.
(cliquetis de la machine)
- Vous traversez votre crise de
la cinquantaine avec des romans
comme "Résonances".
Vous critiquez les wokes.
Vous critiquez aussi ce quevouss
hétéros. Pourquoi cette prise
de parole contre l'extrémisme?
- Bien, parce que c'est ça.
Moi, je voulais pas juste rire
des wokes extrêmes. Je voulais
rire aussi des mononcles
extrêmes. Puis je voulais...
Des fois je suis un mononcle,
puis... Mais il faut dénoncer
ça, l'extrême, parce que
c'est des positions faciles,
les positions extrêmes.
C'est confortable. C'est très
confortable de dire : Je sss
woke à 100 % puis je suis
d'accord avec tout, tout,
et de pas fae e de nuances.
Comme c'est très confortable
aussd'êd'être un vieux con
et de dire : "Bah! Tout ce que
les jeunes font... Ils ont rien
compris. Nous autres, on a
tout compris." Cstst très
confortable comme position
et c'est pas facile pour moi,
parce que, moi aussi, ceux
qui me connaissent, mes am,,
ils savent que je suis capable
d'être... très emporté.
Je suis capable d'être...
(Il imite des grognements.)
... d'exploser. Ça fait que
c'est, moi-même, une leçon que
je veux me donner à moi-même,
là. Cet effort-là que je demande
aux gensjeje me le demande
à moi aussi. Puis des fois,
je l'échappe.
(rire)
- Dans "Résonances" et dans
"Autofission", vous avez pas
la langue dans votre poche, là?
- Non. Non, parce que c'est...
Il y a un espace qu'on peut
encore se permettre de dire
des choses qui peuvent aller
loin, c'esenen littérature.
On ne peut plus à la TV,
on ne peut plus au cinéma.
(rire)
Il y a-tu quelque part qui
reste? Puis je sais, je sais,
puis je les nommerai pas,
mais il y a des éditeurs qui
commencent à ne pas vouloir
certains motdadans leurs livres.
Ils veulent pas...
Ça n'a pas de sens! Moi, le jour
qu'un éditeur va m'empêcher
d'écrire un mot dans un demes l.
Je ne publierai pas là.
C'est sûr, ça. C'est certain.
Certain! Je le dis devant
témoin, là, mais je sais que
j'ai un éditeur qui est pas.
Mais je pense pas qu'il y en a
beaucoup, là.
- Je veux parler de votre
processus d'écriture, parce que
la musique est omniprésente
chez vous. Vous aimez écouter
du Nine Inch Nails, parfois.
- Oui.
- Vous chantez parfois
du Mötley Crüe avec un groupe de
rock.
(rire)
- Mes vieux chum!
- Et là, la veille de
cette entrevue, vous étiez
au karaoké et semble-t-il que
vous chantez très bien "How Deep
Is Your Love" des Bee Gees?
- Mon Dieu, vous êtes bien
renseigné.
- Patrick Sénécal.
- Oui?
Je peux pas. Je peux pas
chanter. Vous vouliez que
je chante?
- Bien là!
- Bien, non. J'arrive du karaoké
la veille. Justement, regardez,
là, j'ai une voix beaucoup
plus rauque que d'habitude,
j'ai la voix brisée.
J'ai aucun verre d'alcool
dans le nez non pl..
Il manque beaucoup d'éléments,
il manque beaucoup d'éléments!
(rires)
Une autre fois, vous viendrez
avec nous, tiens. Je vais
vous la faire.
- Mais vous aimez ça, chanter?
Ça fait partie de...
- Ah oui, oui. Bien, oui,
j'aime ça, puis je connais pas
beaucoup de ndnde qui, une fois
qui sont sur la scène avec leur
micro, même si on les pousse
à 14 pour les envoyer sur
la scène, une fois qu'ils ont
chanté, il font : "Câline que
c'est libérateur puis que c'est
le fun!" C'est très, très...
même si on est pas bon,
même si des fois on fausse,
même si on est... C'est
un espacenencore de liberté
absolue, puis personne juge
personne. On est juste là
pour avoir du fun.
- Où voulez-vous aller
maintenant? Parce que vous
changez de style constamment
dans les derniers romans, et
c'est ce qu'on apprécie aussi.
- Bien, je suis content que
vous disiez ça, parce que
j'essa d de me lancer des défis
dans le dernier roman,
effectivement, pour pas répéter.
T'sais, faire du genre... faire
du roman noir comme je le fais,
le piège, c'est justement
la redite. Parce que je sais
qu'il y a des lecteurs qui
voudraient que je fasse
"Aliss" 2, 3, 4, 5....
Bon, ou "Hell.com" 2, 3, 4.
Je le sais, là! Je me le fai
demander tout le temps.
Mais, moi, ça me tente pas.
Ça me tente pas. Je dis pas que
je le ferai jamais, mais là-là,
ça me tente pas. T'sais, AC/DC,
ça fait 40 ans qu'ilfofont le
même disque, là. Je veux pas...
- Puis? Bien là!
- Bien, en tout cas, moi,
je suis tanné. Moi, je suis
écoeuré. Moi, ils m'ont perdu.
Bien, manifeemement non,
parce qu'ils vendent encore!
(Louis-Philippe rit.)
Ça fait que je pense qu'il y a
bien du monde qui sont pas